[Music]
so in preparation for the new generation
of GPUs around the corner I decided to
expand my benchmark stack and one card
that I picked up was AMD SRX 570 now
this card and its predecessor the RX 470
have a bit of a weird history because of
the whole cryptocurrency mining rush the
RX 470 in my opinion was one of the best
GPUs that AMD has put out in recent
times and was really the only card from
their lineup to consistently beat what
Nvidia had to offer at the same price
range which was the GTX 1050 TI
cryptocurrency changed that
significantly though and it's the main
reason why I uploaded this video where I
talked about why the 1050 Ti was a much
better option than the RX 470 because
the arcs for seventies prices had been
sparked up quite a lot by the way that
video is one of my most popular with
almost half a million views so it
definitely interested quite a few of you
however the cryptocurrency mining craze
has died down significantly with Bitcoin
now down to six thousand USD from its
all-time high $20,000 per coin and the
theorem is also down to three hundred
from its all-time high around 1400 now
this has done two positive things for
the market the first one is that a lot
of cryptocurrency miners are selling
their cards in bulk and usually for a
pretty decent price as well the second
thing is that common wining cards like
the rx 570 have become more abundant in
terms of shelf stock which means that
pricing is a lot more competitive among
retailers using the rx 570 as an example
it launched in April last year at 169 US
dollars but then price started to climb
immediately to the point where in April
this year
finding one under 350 was near
impossible today though they can be had
for a little over $200 u.s. and I'm
guessing that price will fall closer and
closer to MSRP as time goes on and if
you're lucky you can get your hands on
one for around 170 with a mail-in rebate
now having said all that should you be
looking to buy an RX 570 since the price
has come down I mean I just said at the
start of the video that new GPUs are on
the way now if you haven't been keeping
up with all the rumors and whatnot and
video are planning on releasing the 2080
TI and 2080 in a couple days but you
probably won't see budget cards and
competitors to these cards until the end
of the year at least that's what they
did with the 10 series and the 900
series which means that the competitors
for the rx 570 will remain to be until
at least the end of the year the gtx
1050 the 1050 TI and the gtx 1063
gigabyte in terms of pricing the 1050 Ti
is almost a direct competitor at just
under $200 at the time of filming with
the 1063 gigabyte also at a very
reasonable 200 to 220 at some retailers
and the gtx 1050 is also starting to
approach MSRP at around 120 at the time
of filming so if you are in the market
for a budget card let's take a look at
which one of these will be the best
option given that current pricing let's
start things off with player unknowns
battlegrounds and since these are budget
cards I have restricted the testing to
1080p resolution at around high settings
here there was quite a disparity between
performance the gtx 1050 here was not
able to maintain 60fps on average and
since this game needs a bit of
optimization the 1% and 0.1% will suffer
a little bit across the board the RX 570
does fill the gap between the 1050 Ti
and d3 you buy gtx 1060 yo but the 1060
is the much better choice if you can get
it at a good price and that theme starts
to set in the gtx 960 is way ahead here
able to push 110 FPS on average in
fortnight with the RX 570 and 1050 Ti
around 79 and 74 FPS respectively the JT
x 1050 was much more playable here I
will add so if you don't mind medium to
low settings in this game you'll
probably get away with just the 1050 in
Rainbow six siege though the times do
turn for the radeon GPU as it's now able
to edge out the three gigabyte gtx 1060
with an average FPS of 88.5 and it's
also leading the 1050 Ti by almost 50%
for the same price pretty unreal
the 1050 Ti does catch up though in GTA
5 or rather there isn't a massive
difference between the 1050 1050 TI or
RX 570 in this title but stepping up to
the 3 gigabyte gtx 1060 will net you a
much better playing experience with an
average FPS of over 100
the results are much more spread out in
Ghost Recon wildlands with fairly even
jumps between each GPU the GTX 750
suffers a ridiculous amount here with
the 0.1% loads far below the rest of the
stack and this was even off the testing
that's tied with lower texture settings
given that 2 gigabytes of video memory
to accommodate some testing overwatch
played quite well and here we're testing
frame rate in a 5 minute round in a bot
match so there might be some margin of
error here even when taking the average
of three rounds
the 1063 gigabyte takes the lead here as
you would expect with the RX 570 roughly
10 percent lower here but with a
strongly 0.1% of frames in battlefield 1
the RX 570 has the strongest 1% and 0.1%
frame rate results in a stack here a
considerable amount better on average
also against the 1050 Ti and not too far
behind the 3 gigabyte 1060 the radeon
GPU proves itself again in witcher 3
when compared against the 1050 Ti but it
isn't enough to catch the 3 year by 1060
which is a really outstanding performer
here granted you can get it at a decent
price in Civilization 6 were recording
average and 1% fps results using the
built-in graphics benchmark here we can
see very similar results to the rest of
the games that we've tested with the 3d
1060 leading by a considerable amount
again and lastly the division shows
again the 1060 leading but the more
interesting metric key is the margin
between the RX 570 and the 1050 Ti this
is what surprised me the most when
looking at their current pricing and
when looking at the average of all 10
games the radeon GPU is the much better
option against the 1050 TI in fact the
1050 Ti is a hard sell at the moment .
yes it's over 17 percent faster than the
vanilla 1050 but it also cost you 60%
more at the time of filming at the same
price sometimes lower the rx 570 is a
much more compelling option yielding
over a 28% faster average frame rate
over the 1050 Ti if you can squeeze just
a little bit more cash flow stepping up
to the three gig 1060 will net you
another 17 or so percent on your average
FPS the video memory is 25% lower at
three gigabytes but that's only going to
be an issue for those playing games with
demanding texture packs or ramping
temperatures up to ultra which I doubt
many of you will
with these cards so looking at current
US pricing the RX 570 is a clear steal
over the 1050 TI with almost a 30%
margin between them in favor of the RX
570 the conversation then becomes four
gigabyte rx 570 versus three gigabytes
gtx 1060 and it really depends on the
pricing in your region if pricing does
look anything like the u.s. pricing does
right now where the gtx 1063 gig is
about 20 to 30 dollars more than the RX
574 gig I would personally be throwing
in that extra twenty to thirty dollars
for that extra 15 or so percent of
performance on the 1060 the GTX 1050 is
also a very compelling budget option at
the moment as pricing is starting to
approach that MSRP of around $100 and
you can pick one up for around 120 130
these days performance isn't too far off
the 1050 Ti as well you know about 15 or
so percent but you don't want to spend
that extra 60% like we just said as
always guys let me know what you think
of these results and if you're planning
on picking up any of these cards feel
free to check them out in the link below
or perhaps you're waiting for what
Nvidia does next I sure AM
I can't wait to see the performance of
those mutual GPUs but like I said we
probably won't see any budget
competition until towards the end of
this year as always guys a huge thanks
for watching subscribe if you haven't
already and I'll see you all in the next
one
[Music]
you